want to guess how much the highest paid
youtuber earned last year like and
subscribe to our forbes youtube channel
to find out just kidding so the highest
paid youtuber in history is mr beast
he earned a record-breaking 54 million
dollars in 2021. in the past year he has
spent 50 hours buried alive offered 10
000 to anyone willing to sit in a
bathtub of snakes and hosted his own
version of squid game
number two is jake paul one of youtube's
biggest names until a controversy in
but he's back on the list with earnings
of 21.8 million dollars nearly three
quarters of that comes from his newfound
career in boxing
nowadays jake posts less frequently than
he once did using the site mostly to
market his boxing career
hello everybody my name is markiplier
markiplier first became famous by
recording himself playing video games
few social media stars can move merch
like markiplier who saw especially
strong sales tied to his eunice honest
series in 2021 he filmed the television
adaption of the edge of sleep a popular
post-apocalyptic thriller he initially
dramatized as a podcast in 2019. the
project still needs a home and he's
hoping to sell the series to a company
like netflix or hulu later this year
good mythical morning rhett and link
started off hosting good mythical
morning a daily talk show that has grown
into something of a mythical empire one
of their most successful efforts is
mythical kitchen a cooking series with a
separate host in october they satisfied
a long time fan request to drop their
family friendly act hosting a two-hour
decidedly r-rated live stream event to
which they sold seventy thousand tickets
for as much as fifty dollars a pop
number five is unspeakable over 20
million people subscribe to his four
youtube channels where he posts videos
of himself playing minecraft and other
games
he also dabbles with youtube's stunt
sub-genre doing things like filling a
room with live alligators last year
unspeakable also sold off his catalog of
youtube videos to spotter one of the
largest independent owners of youtube
content
the youngest youtuber on this year's
list is nastia a seven-year-old
originally from southern russia she also
recently sold her catalog of youtube
videos to spot her she retains the right
to any new videos she puts up though top
hits from 2021 include her videos about
decorating halloween cupcakes and about
spending time with her best friends
evelyn and adrian
in the meantime she and her corporate
minders have added other brand
extensions including a merchandise line
and an nft collection
another incredibly successful child on
this list is ten-year-old ryan kajii
who's been making videos since he was
four
now that he's aging out of playtime his
parents and the others guarding his
business interests including former
disney executive chris williams are
increasingly focused on keeping his
brand alive
ryan's worlds maintains 31 million
subscribers on youtube and an enormous
line of branded merchandise and toys
sold at big box retailers like target
and walmart red titan a child superhero
with a crimson cape and a passing
resemblance to ryan has become well
known enough to appear as a macy's
thanksgiving day parade balloon for the
past two years
dude perfect is number eight with the
sports comedy fivesome doing wild stunts
like bench pressing 405 pounds
underwater and walking on a biplane's
wings mid-flight
the group will do their third live tour
this summer in 24 cities they also
published a 250 page photo filled book
complete with step-by-step instructions
at the number 9 spot is jake paul's
brother logan
he returned to the list thanks to a
successful year as a boxer fighting
former world champion floyd mayweather
in an exhibition logan has also had one
of the first celebrity nft releases last
february a sale that did over five
million dollars
number 10 is preston arsman he runs
several youtube channels but the name of
his most popular one prestonplays says
all you really need to know about it the
guy plays a lot of video games mostly
minecraft
collectively these 10 youtubers earned
about 300 million dollars in 2021 to pad
their pay further all these stars have
branded merchandise lines and dabble in
generating additional revenue off of
twitch snap facebook podcasts nfts and
even restaurants
you